codes I mean that when you get into the
Divine Union when there is the sacred
honor in the sexual then what happens is
there's an intensifying of the of that
polarity of the of God relating with
itself like the godhead with itself in
that sacred container is a feedback loop
on identifying what is sacred creativity
of that gives and it's crazy cuz some
it's not penetrative is what I'm saying
it's just that the honor in the sexual
has been sealed in that way and because
of that then all of these things start
getting like full body activations
better than quote any like Med
meditation
psychedelic yeah chasing sex or chasing
a material luxurious material object
those things are all like quote like
your quote temporary uh highs or
whatever I mean like an
orgasmic dance of God for like minute
minutes and hours and then days weeks
years